tim mcgraw and faith hill's daughter
gracie is following in the footsteps of
her superstar parents showcasing her
stunning vocal talents once again yeah
gracie took to instagram to share a
video of herself performing i'm not that
girl from the musical wicked take a look
[Music]
far
don't lose
[Music]
your daughter oh sing a song like that
you would be a puddle i know like
i know i cry all the time anyways but
yeah it is so beautiful to see that that
their daughter wants to do what they're
doing and that she's inspired by them
and of course the talent i mean of
course you're getting it from your
parents and she's it was emotional
yeah for sure i don't know about you but
every time i see my kids perform on a
stage or they do anything yeah where
they're putting themselves out there and
they're being vulnerable like you
immediate tears i was at a dance recital
recently for my daughter
someone else's daughter who i didn't
know was dancing and i was bawling and
this lady goes is that your daughter i'm
like no it's just so beautiful
it's like okay
but so when you see young people putting
themselves out there i think that's why
we love our job is we get to see so many
different talents yeah but it touches
you inside right yeah i mean
it's interesting to see what mike i mean
my kids are getting older they're
teenagers uh they're not following my
career or maybe sam's career actually
ava ava may go towards sam's career but
one of the things that made me cry last
week was the girls were playing
volleyball shallow was playing
volleyball and uh shh that the sand was
hot and so she gave her socks to her
this other team another kid makes her
feet were hot and that made me cry i'm
like that's the best that was the
sweetest thing so yeah anything when
your kids are and the best part is when
they're inspired and they want to show
their best that's where you feel the
most emotions right
absolutely whatever career they go in
yeah um common here is a pretty good
singing high e.t canada from greece oh
that's so sweet um yeah people are
loving they're going to greece i am
going to greece i just told cheryl i'm
going to greece tomorrow so i'm gone for
a week girl
yeah i'm gone